faites votre rentrée en music hall à
paris très bientôt
oui enfin on appelle ça une rentrée mais
en fait moi je n'ai jamais quitté bobino
parce que je suis toujours retourner par
la pensée je puis leur antre nous sommes
environnés de disques et j'en ai un ici
qui s'appelle terre qui est très
important je crois pour vous taire
charles trenet et le jazz de paris ce
qui veut dire au fond que vous étiez un
des premiers piliers ou d'un style de
l'époque dias de paris le voici avec
trenet
c'est la première fois que sur scène
envoyer quelqu un qui chantait des
rythmes des chansons de rythme au jeu
vous avez chanté avant des chansons de
rythme en 1937 à mes débuts à la bc j'ai
débuté en novembre 37 abc avec je chante
d'équité des chansons le dos de riz si
l'on retourne le disque du moins la face
nous tombons sur verlaine et verlaine là
aussi c'est un essai d'auteur
compositeur mais là vous faites comme
brassens il ya maintenant dix ans vous
prenez votre compte des poèmes de gens
connus
we7 ce poème s'appelle dans leur de
verlaine chanson d'automne
demaci je trouvais que le titre ne
rendait pas ces hommages à verlaine pour
une chanson l'orphelin intitulé verlaine
et il ya même des gens qui se sont
trompés sur le sens du mot verlaine des
gens qui ne connaissaient pas que
verlaine en tant que poète et j'avais
une petite admiratrice qui m'écrivait à
l'époque elle signé votre petit verlaine
elle croyait que c'était une fleur comme
marjolaine ces gens qui savait qu'on dit
très souvent sont toujours avec les
pétés un peu jazz d'ailleurs
oui on dit très souvent que s'il n'y
avait pas eu charles trenet il n'y
aurait pas eu ce passage est arrêté à ce
niveau il réveille et qu est-ce que vous
en êtes conscient c'est la voix je
trouve que ce n'est pas très gentil pour
les autres de dire ça je pense pas que
ce soit tellement près et vous savez on
a évidemment on s'inspire toujours ce
qui a eu un avant vous et ça c'est ainsi
quand ça vous plaît mais je ne pense pas
parce que ces garçons auraient trouvé à
s'exprimer aussi à leur manière vous
pauvres défini farès rennais comme en
fait mais moi je ne me définis pas du
tout heureusement que le public défini
je ne savais pas du tout une fois quand
j'avais décidé après mon service
militaire de chanter tout seul parce que
je chantais avec geniès comme partenaire
et je vais voir mon éditeur breton je
lui dit il faut que je chante tout seul
maintenant parce que johnny chante de
son côté qu'est ce que je vais bien
pouvoir faire comme genre il me dit mais
fait le jean charles trenet et moi je ne
savais pas ce que ça pouvait être que ça
pouvait être un genre et d'ailleurs je
n'en sais pas plus maintenant
heureusement de temps dans le public me
le dit mais je crois que le public le
public saisi plusieurs facettes de mon
personnage mais les saisit pas tout à la
fois alors pour certains publics je suis
le fou chantant qui fait ça et je le
suis vraiment aussi pour d'autres reçu
un type qui chante des choses qu'on perd
très profondes et des rites gauche
quitte la fois le conte plein ces choses
là
et puis pour d'autres cieux peut être
léger qui chante des chansons
gentillette comme j'étais à manama mme
un film en moi même je ne sais pas
exactement fichiers le public me le dit
à chaque représentation
heureux
il ya aussi
et dieu merci pas des fous
hu si vous aviez réécrire
moi j'aime le music hall qui a ajouté à
cette liste or je mettrais jacques brel
bien sûr jean ferrat c'est tout à fait
naturel d'ailleurs je le dis quand je
suis sur scène et puis il faudrait faire
deux chansons maintenant pour les citer
tous
ah oui
selon
la main au corps ou encore difficile
avait tissé les fils avaient centré
sinon ça japonais la mer dans le fond
est un succès amérique quand je les
chante et en france on m'a dit c'est
très gentil mais ce n'est pas assez
swing à l'époque il fallait chanter du
swing quand ben ali s'est passé swing
c'est pas votre genre et la mère est
restée trois ans dans un tiroir
ne pensez pas que vous prenez un risque
en faisant votre rentrée les édits
public français qui vous a maintenant
ont pas oublié mais qui ne vous a pas
entendu et vu sur scène depuis mon vélo
aucun risque aucun risque devant des
gens charmants pourquoi le public et il
a toujours été très gentil pour moi il
va pas s'arrêter du jour au lendemain
ce serait un risque si j'étais minable
je suis en bonne santé grâce à dieu en
bonne forme je vais chanter les chansons
le public les aimera j'en suis certaine
vous avez chanté la mer bien sûr si le
s'ils le veulent je ressens très tout ce
qu'ils voudront je suis on va se
retrouver comme de comme des gens d'une
même famille dans le fond c'est ça
pourquoi avoir peur des gens qui vous
aiment